joining us right now is John Smoltz here
in the Rich Eisen show how are you John
I'm good thanks are the baseball's
juiced let's start right there what do
you think seems to be the topic right it
seems to be people are talking about how
tightly wound these baseball's are I
thought I heard the documentation of
Commissioner saying that wasn't the case
but you know baseball's are being hit at
a tremendous rate of distance but I know
guys are stronger and I know pitchers
are pitching faster and that could be a
combination of it but I I've heard that
I obviously have no way of knowing I
should probably grab a couple peel them
and throw them and but I can't throw
anymore no no but I guess that that was
going to be my question for you Johnny's
could you be able to in the same way
that we had that whole conversation
during the deflategate insanity that a
professional thrower of a football can
grab a football and pretty much tell
whether it's overinflated or under
inflated can you tell if a ball is
juiced just by grabbing it or you
definitely can tell the difference
between an all-star homerun Derby ball
and a baseball and I could tell the
difference between a ball that just felt
square in my hand and not round some
feels small or tighter when you when
you've thrown over 250,000 pitches which
I'm sure I have you definitely know the
difference between a ball that feels
good in your hand and a ball that
doesn't to the degree that the firmness
of it and the tightness yeah you could
probably tell there's just a little bit
different between the baseballs but you
know this is just a different era
different launch angles different ways
that guys are trying to hit a baseball
which in and of itself explains why all
the strikeouts are happening and you
know I think the plus/minus on where we
are with homeruns and strikeouts is
still yet to be determined what do you
mean by feels square in your hand John
well when you get the loop the four seam
fastball when you grab in the baseball
sometimes the ball feel oblong and
there's that was the definite for me to
throw it back
not every baseball is made perfectly and
there's some that feel just unbelievable
in your hand you know they call them
pearls but the biggest thing is
when you find one you like and think
about today how many baseball's they go
through a game used to be you could put
a ball and play a couple times in pitch
with it now every ball that's hit gets
pretty much thrown out so there's a
different different rate of which we go
through the baseball's and certainly a
different a different flight of the
baseball than we've ever seen before
well let's just say that the balls have
been wound tighter and let's just say
that has happened is that a problem when
it all comes down to it John I don't
think now I don't think anybody has had
a disadvantage I don't think there's a
problem in that um the fact that
baseball's are being thrown like we said
harder and firmer that's a byproduct of
ball being maybe tighter who knows but
you can spin a baseball so look it's
just it really is whether you like it or
not a game that has changed through
science and it's changed so much through
science that we haven't figured out how
to stop the injuries that's a problem
and it's changed so much that guys now
are being rewarded or not discounted for
the amount of strikeouts they have that
that used to be a detriment that used to
be something that costs you in a long
contest not that's not the case anymore
John Smoltz baseball hall-of-famer
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
so are you saying that their players are
just going up don't care if they get the
golden sombrero as long as they hit one
500 feet in between games like
absolutely absolutely we're more we're
more consumed and infatuated with
velocity and distance and exit velocity
I want to know the analytical statistic
of who has the best exit velocity taking
strikeouts into consideration that
number is going to be lower so what
somebody can hit a ball 119 miles an
hour every once in a while who cares but
that's what baseball is being shoved
down everyone's throat to show the
judges in the stands I want to know what
Tony Glynn would have been Tony Gwynn
would have been one of the lower exit
velocities in the game and he was a stud
and that's the difference so guys don't
alter their swings with two strikes they
don't care they're trying to hit home
runs we had a guy you know young man by
the name of Ian Happ who had a Grand
Slam
and four strikeouts in one game that
looked at as a productive game so you
know that's the difference so when you
manure an agent and you represent a guy
you say looking at 30 whole months and
he's got the capability hitting 40 so
what he struck out 210 times but are you
hearing that general managers are
looking at exit velocity as a an
important metric I know I know baseball
does I know you know when my my MLB app
notifies me that somebody's hit a
baseball with an exit velocity of
such-and-such and I just ignore it that
and that's why we talk old Gen stats on
the show we talk a RA and RBI and you
know an average and homeruns we do but
to me I don't what do I care that
somebody said a ball hard or fast it
doesn't matter to me but does it matter
to general managers and managers for
real yeah they're Scout they're scouting
for this now they're scouting for Los
Angles and exit velocity you're seeing
at a youth baseball I'm hearing parents
of kids talk about their launch angle of
11-year old player like are you kidding
me so this is all the new age technology
that is science and we've basically been
it's been shoved to us to talk about
what this is now the new fad and yes
guys are scouting it's the same thing
with spin rate this become the new thing
spin rate oh you got a good spin rate on
your curveball that's what we're looking
for
well it's not teachable per se to every
guy if you find one guy that has great
spin rate the way he throws it so this
is just part of the game and part of the
knowledge that is out there and people
are deciphering it how they need to and
personally for me I only concern myself
with a man on third less than two outs
in the playoffs I don't care if a guy's
had 118 exit velocity up as bad I only
care if you get football and play and
drive that running amen John Smoltz
baseball hall-of-famer joining me here
how real are the Rockies John how real
real they're real it's a matter of
sustainability for the long run of what
they have to deal with atmosphere wise
they have a greater chance of injuries
because of where they play it's
well-documented their pitchers have to
have and basically a a blanks
in their brain to not to not know
anything which is good they got a
younger step they don't know anything I
love it and they can go through the year
without everybody telling them what's
going to happen that's a good thing but
from a standpoint of are they in a great
position to make the playoffs a hundred
percent they are winning the vision
would be a little bit of a monumental
task not impossible just because of what
the Dodgers can throw at you as far as
resources so impressive story it's one
of the best stories in baseball right
now them in the Arizona Diamondbacks in
the National League so that that West
looks like a runaway right now from the
two wild-card standpoint and then we
look at the American League man the Blue
Jays can't get to 500 up for their here
there now Oh an eighth in games in which
they could get to 500 and but they're
still in the mix here the Orioles have
imploded they can't get anybody out
suddenly the Yankees have had the bottom
fallout for the moment that could be
indicative of a larger picture but now
Chris Sale has led the Red Sox to first
place right now do you think that this
is going to be the general order of
things in the American lease from here
on out I I kind of do from the beginning
of the season I really like Boston I
think everybody that pretty much had
them predicted in that top spot the
Yankees are a great story and a great
surprise and they're hitting a little
bit of a lull they'll be right there by
the end of the season I think two
divisions have a chance to have three
teams come out of the playoffs and I
think it's the less than a National
League in the East and the American
League unless somebody gets really hot I
know everybody is within striking
distance of the of the wild-card that's
a little deceiving especially when
you're talking about the last place team
is five and a half out they think they
have a chance but there's nine teams in
front of them that's a little bit more
daunting than just some of the teams
that are a game or two out so I think
the Red Sox are for real the obvious
team in the mess in the American League
is the Houston Astros who are having a
fantastic season and Cleveland's looking
like they're starting to get back in
gear and then before I let you go I know
you're in your ear as we you know
obviously baseball hall-of-famer but
you're you're an excellent golfer you
you know love all sports you love
football although you root for the
me wrong college football team has been
doctoring you're on the show I'm sure I
don't have you heard but Phil Mickelson
and his longtime caddy
Jim bones McKay have broken up and we
were wondering we were talking about
what's the most important relationship
in sports law do you have the list
tonight off to yes y'all so golfer to
caddy quarterback to offensive
coordinator or head coach picture to
catcher or fighter to trainer boxer UFC
what do you think out of those choices
that's a great list and very complicated
and diverse you know look the Caddy is
much like a catcher and as far as a
pitcher coaxing him being able to give
him opportunities through positive
reinforcement you name it a trainer is
important obviously a boxer I'm going to
have to say that I'm going to go off the
board a little bit if I say the
offensive coordinator with the
quarterback I think that being in sync
there makes that game move and flow a
little bit quick yet you have very
little time to make those decisions to
translate what's coming in and be able
to process whether you have to call out
call to another play or not and being in
sync would would certainly have helped
the Falcons last year they were when
they were up and letting the Super Bowl
nose down you could take place you could
say that again did you ever have a
personal catcher I don't recall that
John in the same way that all I did I
did ask for I did ask for Brian McCann
when he caught got called up from Bobby
I said please let me throw to this young
man and we won seven in a row when he
got called up so that was probably the
closest thing I had to a so-called
personal catcher but I didn't have one
in theory and in that regard then what
what what does how does that how did the
other catcher react to a a future Hall
of Fame or saw young winners saying I
want that guy and the other guy just
sits when ordinarily they might start
how does that work he didn't know about
it it's just that simple just is that B
is happen to be the young young guy
needed to get him with get him a games
you know and I was
to get in the game and to in so yeah you
didn't know about it okay John take care
thanks for calling all right love it
thanks you got it that's John Smoltz
baseball hall-of-famer here on the
Rajasa truck the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint